[Music]
hey
you guys what's up we're laughing about
the dislike
yeah they're like looking at the
comments it looks like yeah
i think somebody hit it by accident they
might hit the like and then they took it
away either
they're just [ __ ] around pookie could
have disliked it although she yeah she's
on the back
she's on the back porch she's outside
she's like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
because i'm not on the thing yeah she
hits it with her little mitten
yeah yeah so it's thursday and we don't
usually live stream today but i thought
because we were so tired on tuesday and
we didn't live stream i was like well
that's not really fair to
everybody that's used to us live
streaming five days a week so
let's do it today and it so happened
that netflix just added a new
adam sandler movie yeah it was good that
was halloween themed
yeah so i was like yeah why not this is
kind of like
adam sandler's version of crustal's
christmas movie
you know christmas chronicles yeah
christmas chronicles 2 is supposed to be
coming out this year
i thought it was yeah it's like i'm
excited to see that so it looks like
[ __ ] sandler said oh
i can do halloween
he jumped on halloween and it's an
all-star cast
you'll recognize you know if you watch
movies you'll recognize everybody well
he makes this
he makes movies with pretty much all the
same people it's like you know it's just
ben stiller
uh rob schneider like yeah kevin james
like all this all the same people that
you gotta make movies with got the woman
from mediocracy the one that played yeah
randolph think that's her name she's in
it
um tim meadows was in it the shack isn't
it yeah
uh who else was in it like a [ __ ] ton of
people steve buscemi was in it yeah ray
liotta was in it
yeah it's it's [ __ ] zany you know
what i mean it's almost
trying to go along go along lines of
kind of like evil dead zaniness
but it's a different tone yeah it's a
different tone to me it
it reminded me of like a crass
goosebumps movie
yeah you know what i'm saying you
remember that goosebumps movie like that
we saw in the theater
like this is kind of like a kid's move
like it's kind of had tonally is kind of
like a kids movie
but it's clearly not a kid's movie
because it's like just all like
disgusting humor
yeah you know what i mean yeah and adam
sandler you know
look if you want to see a good adam
sandler movie you want to see [ __ ]
uncut just uncut jams or punch drunk
love or spanglish
gems is [ __ ] badass gangster movie
it's like jewish
new york jewish gangsters down in the
[ __ ] diamond district
and how they [ __ ] did [ __ ] or how
this one particular guy did [ __ ]
and it's how he scam people and stuff
it's a [ __ ] great movie
well did we say okay so this he can act
when he has to act yeah
well this movie is called hubie
halloween right yeah so
the joke about this like when i read
some other reviews of it so i guess
i didn't see this personally but i've
seen other people mention it
is that when adam sandler was on like
his press tour
for uncut gems like he made a joke on
the howard stern show that if he didn't
win an oscar for that he was going to
make a really bad movie on purpose
this must be it this isn't it though
because
because this one was already in
production like when the oscars came out
and everything and he did actually get
snubbed which i thought was like
that sucked i mean i'm glad parasite won
but um i think that it should have at
least got nominated
but the thing about it is that so adam
sandler and netflix have had they gave
him like a four picture deal like back
in 2014 and he made those four movies
and apparently they were like so
watched on the platform they gave him
another four picture deal and this is
one of the ones i don't know if this is
the first one
but um so apparently his movies are like
really successful because like i said
i don't watch all of them because i'm
not i like he's
adam sandler is like um he's like a
great actor
but a lot of that like of the real like
juvenile humor and stuff like that it's
like i have to really be in the mood for
that i'm not usually like a big fan
he does the funny voices it kind of got
to me
well i couldn't understand what he was
saying half the time i'm gonna say that
right out the gate because he was just
kind of being
so his the story behind it if it's
important
is that it's i'm not sure it is no
probably not but it's said in salem
yeah and um it's kind of like huby is
sort of like this loser like every
single person in town
just like makes fun of him and hates him
it's just like every time he goes on his
bike like just people are throwing [ __ ]
at him and
everything like that and everyone just
like yeah like kids adult everybody is
just like picking on him all the time
but the thing about it is that he's kind
of an interesting character because
he doesn't like he doesn't get mad at
everybody about it he just kind of like
it's almost kind of like it just rolls
off his back like he's used to that he's
like
and he's like whatever but he's just
like a nice person and his whole thing
is that he loves halloween like more
than anything and he just wants
everybody to be safe on halloween
and [ __ ] like that so he's like dresses
up as a halloween guard appointed
himself like the halloween monitor like
to make
make sure everyone's only taking one
piece of candy out of the bowl and like
it's fine and like so it's that and then
and then you have something where um
a psychopath like escapes from a mental
hospital
and then steve buscemi moves in next to
him
and you're not sure if he's a psychopath
or maybe something else is going on with
that i don't necessarily want to spoil
it should i spoil it i don't know
i guess i guess it doesn't really matter
but it's like so it's kind of set around
like
you know the halloween night and like
all this [ __ ] going like
[ __ ] going bad like people disappearing
and stuff so he's kind of like
sort of has to get to the bottom of it
all the while people are like making fun
of him and like throwing [ __ ] at him and
everything like that
so that's pretty much the the premise
and like i said
all of the people that usually work with
him on these movies
um are in this one too because i guess
like
and honestly as much as i'm like not
a big fan of these types of movies um
i will give adam sandler the props like
you said he when he's in like a really
good project
the dude can act he's not like he's
legit
but he knows that he makes a lot of
money
with just these type of comedies and he
just gives all his friends work
it's like and i've heard that like those
sets like to work on them are like super
fun
and he's just like look i just want to
make a fun movie with all my friends
you know we're all going to get a
paycheck and it'll just be a good time
and then we'll just make all this money
for the movies and you know what that's
he doesn't make any secret about doing
that and that is like
yeah i i respect that hernandez is in
there saying that um
he's kind of like the actor version of
john carpenter where he can be hit or
miss he could either be
excellent or he's not that good yeah he
is but i'd also kind of compare adam
sandler
to um jerry uh jerry lewis
remember jerry lewis yeah jerry lewis
yeah he could act but he did some goofy
ass [ __ ]
yeah but they said in real life you know
he was pretty straight up you know i
mean he was real intelligent jerry lewis
yeah jerry lewis you know that's that's
old i'm sure a lot of you young people
don't know who the [ __ ] that i know
people like jerry who but he would do
he would do just these outrageous movies
with fake teeth and japanese accents and
go through the whole thing
he was kind of like that but um
i liked his best work really was uncut
gems
i loved that movie yeah but that movie
made me like it made me anxious the
whole [ __ ] time through it i was just
like
had a lot of deeper meanings and a
symbolism in it too the the screenplay
the screenplay was written about it it's
a true story it's written about guy's
dad the dude who wrote it it's about his
dad
yeah working down in the [ __ ] in in
the in the
gem district down in new york and they
called gem
gem district or jewel yeah or something
like that came out and diamond district
that's what it was called
and uh he was just this jewish gangster
you know but he was cool too but he also
was a
complete [ __ ] over i mean you couldn't
trust him with money
and it was just all this weird [ __ ] he
would do
he would talk you out of money and then
he'd invest it or bet it and [ __ ]
this and that you were trying to get
your money back and he was
running some kind of scheme to expand
the money and make it he was always like
running a whole bunch of
games in five or six different schemes
like he was on a tightrope at all right
and he thought and just the way it ends
you know what i mean it's a [ __ ]
fantastic
movie about let's just say conflicting
value systems you know he thought it was
about money there are some guys that
they don't give a [ __ ] about the money
yeah they're more about honor based
things and he runs into some trouble
but uh but yeah this movie have fun you
watch it it's not like that but like i
said
um i i actually didn't mind watching
this one even though i kind of knew what
i was getting into because i was like
hey it's halloween themed and pretty
much
if i love halloween so it's like
anything that's halloween themed i'll
watch it i don't really care
so it's like i really really liked um
you know it really did kind of put you
in the halloween spirit kind of thing
because they had like a big halloween
carnival and everybody had costumes on
the one guy in it that was dressed like
can i spoil that
the one costume that was in it that was
like my favorite oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's a kid in this who
shows up
in this costume and when i when when we
recognized it about the same time we
couldn't figure out who he was trying to
be
we busted up laughing he's like a
pakistani kid
and he shows up dressed up as freddie
mercury with the [ __ ] teeth and
everything
it was it was i was like i was like hold
on i was going wait wait a minute
oh oh freddie mercury
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] hilarious it was a
good costume yeah
and then once once i saw it i couldn't
stop seeing it it looked like it was
eddie murphy murr
like like freddie mercury yeah standing
there just like you know
that was like that was funny as [ __ ] but
i would say this is a
a good analogy is that this is adam
sandler's halloween movie in the same
way that [ __ ] christmas chronicles as
crustals
although like i said i don't know if i'd
necessarily call this a family movie or
like a kids movie because there's a lot
of like it's really really like crass
they're not the same tone yeah at all
uh they're uh adam said adam sandler one
is really irreverent
all right and it's [ __ ] got a lot of
[ __ ] you know dirty jokes you know in
it
a lot of puking a lot of farting
[Laughter]
yeah it just is what it is yeah we were
drinking and having a good time it's
you know you don't have to it's also
like a laugh a minute movie yeah i mean
there's a joke in it
every [ __ ] few seconds i mean i
didn't think it was hilarious
no but it was interesting it was amusing
i think the funniest thing about it was
his thermos
that was what made me laugh it was like
the running gag about his magic thermos
yeah you know what i mean it's like
go-go gadget [ __ ] then he could like
he built it in boy scouts or whatever he
said and it could like do whatever he
needed it to do like for that particular
scene that like made me laugh like every
single time
it's it's a decent movie it's not his
best movie but it's it's it's it's it's
fun
you know it's a small movie honestly i
kind of i'm not
i'm going to say i think i liked it
better than the last adam sandler when i
want which wasn't uncut gems but his
other netflix one murder mystery
that one was okay but i liked this one
better probably
just because um of the halloween theme
because like i said i love halloween
themed [ __ ] i'll even watch
goosebumps movies i don't i don't care i
don't care if they're for kids
but it's like because i just like that
whole aesthetic so you know
like like i said there's a lot of
vomiting in it there's a lot of
you know stupid jokes his i will say
that like the voice he was doing
was like annoying i mean i guess i got
used to it after a while but like at
first i was just like what are you even
saying dude it's like i can't even
understand what you're saying
i know that's kind of his shtick like
doing different voices and why not
but there's he was just like it was he
was very like marble-mouthed
so i couldn't really like a lot of times
i was just i wish i'd put the
usually i have the closed captioning on
because i'm deaf as [ __ ] but
sandra says she's never seen an adam
sandler movie doesn't sound like her
her type of humor if you want to see a
adam sandler move the first one probably
to see
that he in terms of comedy would
probably be the waterboy
i like that one a lot of people seem to
like happy gilmore as well
yeah that's probably i don't think i've
seen that one but um
waterboy was good but really his best
movie is on cut gems and that's only
from a couple years ago i really
recommend that one that's a good movie i
loved that movie it was excellent
but yeah that's the thing that you know
that's
it's it's gonna be like up to you if
you're not into like real low brow
humor then you're not gonna find this
funny in the least
i don't think yeah i mean like i said i
didn't think it was hilarious
but there were a couple things in there
that there were a couple things in there
that made me bust out loud
it's on netflix it's a free [ __ ]
halloween movie with an all-star cast
you gotta see it yeah that's what i got
netflix so what's the problem it'll be a
good thing to watch like on halloween
night you know
like once you're uh a few a few drinks
in
yeah that'd be a good thing to watch
hopefully [ __ ] hopefully uh
christmas chronicles 2 is supposed to be
coming out i hope that comes out this
year because i was
i was amazed because i'm not a big fan
of christmas movies i usually just skip
them because they're mostly like this
[ __ ] lifetime like
yeah i found love for christmas and all
that [ __ ] but it's like and i don't
want to watch that
even though i love christmas too i'm not
saying that but a lot of christmas
movies are just like really shitty and
bad
but i mean that movie was
a delight yeah it was a delight it's
kind of like an old spielberg flick
it was so i'm kind of hoping the second
one comes out
you had crustal's interpretation of what
a [ __ ] santa should be you know what
i mean
santa carries a [ __ ] 45. well like
you would make a fly you never know when
you might need it
[ __ ] reindeer flying and [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's extra dimensional
he's got all kinds of [ __ ] and a
little bit grumpy just a little bit yeah
but i liked that a little bit goes to
jail and puts on a [ __ ] concert
yeah santa goes to jail goes to jail
yeah he had the hookers as the [ __ ]
background
yeah there were hookers it's good yeah
it's a good movie man i mean
christmas movies with hookers in it you
can't yeah you know you can't
really be here man cops tried to arrest
him
he knew what [ __ ] the cops name were
[ __ ] he had presents from them from
back when they were back in the [ __ ]
in the 70s when they were little kids
remember you wanted this one he's
pulling [ __ ] out
did you did you ever get the [ __ ]
star wars you know yeah all that kind of
stuff and
he knew what you wanted for christmas
yeah and it was like all in this bag
because
the bag was extra dimensional also which
i thought was kind of neat
like i liked when she crawled inside the
bag and it was just like yeah this other
device
never ending yeah and somebody reminded
me in the
comments that is it today or tomorrow
that the haunting of bly manor
uh is supposed to come out on netflix
which i'm really excited about because
that's
that's like the second season of
haunting of hill house but it's based on
turn of the screw
um and you know mike flanagan directed
it so i'm like really really
excited that's a series i don't think i
saw the first i don't think i watched it
twice because it's [ __ ] excellent i
saw it and that was based on
obviously that was based on haunting a
pill house the shirley jackson book well
it was loosely based on that it was just
kind of like
a takeoff point then they went with
their own direction so i'm really kind
of interested to see
what they're gonna do with it i still
haven't watched ratchet yet either like
i've
i was like all set to watch it the
series because it looks super cool like
i really like the look of it and it's
like american horror story which i'm you
know i'm kind of hit or miss about i've
only seen like
you know an episode here and there but
then i started seeing like some of my
friends were like oh man i started
watching ratchet and it was like so so
bad and i was just like really it really
doesn't
it looks good but now i'm like scared to
watch it
so i don't know if any of you guys have
seen it like can tell me if it's any
good or not because i don't know
teasers look good yeah that's what i'm
saying so i don't know how much time i
want to invest in it but
i don't know we'll see maybe that's the
thing it's like maybe those people were
just
like didn't like it and i'll like it
because that's
how that [ __ ] happens but like i said
haunting a blind manner i'm really
excited about
but yeah this movie um qb halloween i
think they must have just added this
because i thought i looked on netflix
the day before yesterday and i didn't
see it and then i looked at it last
night and then there it was and i was
like oh adam sandler
halloween maybe why not give me a bloody
mary and we'll
watch it it was fun like i said if
you're if you're into crass humor you
just have to know that that's what
you're getting into that it's like an
adam sandler movie tm like with all the
other saturday night live alumnus that
he usually works with and
like like i said everyone's gonna be
peeing and farting and
whatnot so it's like just just know that
going in
but it's halloween themed and it's fun
and it's funny and the thermos thing is
funny
and the guy that dresses like freddie
mercury is very funny
oh remember that what the one kid that's
in it and remember they had like the
the r.i.p at the end like he died yeah i
looked it up because i was like how did
that guy die that's crazy
because he was like a kid yeah uh he
died of uh epilepsy
weird twenty an epileptic seizure yeah
damn
like complications having to do with
epilepsy or something like that that's
what it sounds wicked
sometimes you can get the seizure and
fall down and hit your head and it
[ __ ] makes a
blood hammer you know brain death that's
true it might be that epilepsy is scary
man fool
yeah i'd be scared by that but yeah so
if you know like i said if you want to
get in the halloween spirit
it's free and you don't mind some vomit
then
then have a drink and watch it and i
guess that'll do it for today we uh
probably won't stream tomorrow but we
will be back on saturday to stream the
main episode
which should be a really fun one so uh
we'll see you guys
on saturday and uh thanks for watching
bye bye